le département de la réunion aux côtés
des réunionnais le chèque marmaille est
une compétence facultative du
département ce dispositif vient aider
les parents en activité ou en recherche
d'activités pour la garde de leurs
enfants
à qui s'adresse-t-il si vous êtes
parents d'enfants âgés de moins de 6 ans
et que vous les faites garder par une
assistante maternelle agrée ou dans une
structure d'accueil de jeunes enfants
ce dispositif vous concerne pourront
disposer votre quotient familial de la
caf ne doit pas dépasser les seuils
indiqués vous pouvez retirer un dossier
dans la pmi la plus proche de chez vous
ou le télécharger directement sur le
site du département au www.cegedim.fr
vous pouvez également appeler le 02 62
90 07 48
le chèque marmaille est un dispositif
qui renforce l'action sociale du
département en faveur des familles
réunionnaises
et